-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
That is so, so good to hear.
Let's get to the news.
Today was Earth Day.
"Ah, yes, the place
I'm totally from,"
said Mark Zuckerberg.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
today was Earth Day,
even though I didn't plan it
[ Laughter ]
So I didn't want to do that joke
and, when I read it today,
because the jokes are submitte
with names on it,
I saw that Ian wrote it.
Then, I did some digging
and Baze told me
that Mike Scollins wrote i
and put Ian's name on it.
[ Laughter ]
That's the kind of monster
Mike Scollins is.
That's his friend.
He did that to his friend.
Tanks for nothing.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden today
announced a pledge
to reduce U.S. greenhouse ga
emissions by 50%, by 2030.
Added Biden,
"Of course, that responsibilit
will ultimately fall
to President The Rock."
[ Laughter ]
Teenage climate activist
Greta Thunberg
addressed a House Subcommittee
on Environment today
to discuss
fossil fuel subsidies,
though it wasn't
encouraging that,
every time she said fossil fuel,
Republicans did the wave.
New York Mayor Bill de Blasi
yesterday announced
a $30 million ad campaign to get
tourists back to the city.
Oh, that's weird. I though
they were back already.
When asked, in a new interview
about the prospect
of actor Matthew McConaughey
running for governor of Texas,
former President George W. Bus
said he did not know
if McConaughey had a chanc
to win and added,
"It's a tough business."
Is it?
I mean, you won twice.
[ Laughter ]
Russian President Vladimir Putin
yesterday delivered
his annual state of the nation
address and, as always,
the state of the nation wa
none of your business.
[ As Putin ]
You ask too many questions
[ Laughter ]
Andrew Giuliani,
the son of former
New York Mayor Rudy Giuliani
said yesterday that he
is considering running
for governor of New York
to beat Andrew Cuomo.
Alright, that's it!
Can the large adult sons
of famous New Yorkers
stop thinking they can jus
skip their way into politics
Because we all know the only
dependable son in New York
is PC Richard's son.
[ Whistling tune plays ]
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
it said, "sound effects"
on the cards and I forgot!
[ Laughter ]
Let me tell you
about what I got.
12,000 BTU WallMaster AC uni
installed same-day
in the dead of August.
August! Total life-saver.
Call 'em, ask for Frank,
tell them Seth sent you.
They'll give you 15% off.
Now, what were we talking about?
[ Laughter ]
A new study suggests
that the Pfizer and Modern
coronavirus vaccines
pose no serious risks
during pregnancy.
The biggest risk
during pregnancy still remains
the gender reveal party.
It was announced yesterday tha
the popular '90s toy Tamagotch
will return to stores
this summer,
which leads
to even bigger news --
there are still going to b
stores this summer.
You haven't won, yet, Amazon
After sex doll company RealDol
unveiled a doll
that can be programmed
to say anything,
one user posted a video online
of a sex doll ranting
about how despicable
the human race is
and, if anybody's
in a position to know that
it's a sex doll.
"You people are disgusting."
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
Taco Bell announced yesterda
that it will partner
with a company
to begin recycling
its hot sauce packets --
and, now, the bad news --
into meat.
[ Laughter ]
And that was the monologue